avec la rentrée s'ouvre aussi la période
des vendanges et tout particulièrement
dans l'est de la seine et marne le
ramassage du raisin qui va servir à
fabriquer certains champagnes ramassage
qui se fait à la main les producteurs
s'organisent donc pour les derniers
préparatifs
les vendanges débuteront dans une
vingtaine de jours l'enquète de sam
diallo et yves de wulf la seine et marne
terres viticoles terroir à champagne ce
n'est pas une boutade en plein coeur du
département neuf vignerons se partagent
20 hectares de vigne qui s'étendent sur
trois communes saâcy-sur-marne sitri et
nanteuil
il ya cette époque de l'année comme dans
la plupart des régions viticoles le
raisin est arrivé à maturité
l'heure des vendanges a bientôt sonné
tout doit être prêt avant l'arrivée des
vendangeurs ans a marqué les vignes soit
bien bien aéré pour éviter la s'il y
avait du mauvais temps la pourriture
faciliter la la caquette le champagne de
seine-et-marne ne respecte les
traditions de méthode champenoise
classique trois cépages sont utilisés
pinot meunier et pinot noir et
chardonnay et jusqu'à la dernière minute
les pieds de vigne sont examinées une
belle grappe bien serré qu'il a ou
lafleur s'est très bien passé par contre
sur cette grappe si on voit des petits
grains ou des grains qui ont coulé au
moins daeffler parce que ce moment là
que les fleurs sont développées il est
fait appel a dû pleuvoir ou ne passe pas
c'est chaud peu connu le champagne de
seine-et-marne ne suscite toujours
autant d'étonnement et de curiosité
lorsqu'il est évoquée mais dans sa
région de production
les viticulteurs sont les premiers à
défendre ardemment ses qualités
maintenant les méthodes de vinification
veulent que
on arrive à avoir quand même des bons
produits tout neuf tout en étant dans
une région quand même avec des crus
périphériques sa faux faux faux quand
même le reconnaître
et puis bon le problème c'est qu'il faut
pas travailler avec dédain jeunes moi
c'est mon optique je travaille avec des
violents et comme ça on arrive à voir
quelque chose d'assez constant au niveau
qualité et puis quelque chose qui tient
un peu la honte quoi l'an dernier 2 190
mille bouteilles ont été produites selon
les professionnels la récolte 99 devrait
être légèrement en hausse les
producteurs devront en effet désormais
faire face à d'importantes aux commandes
en raison du réveillon de l'an 2000